Un flot de questions est sorti de la bouche d'enfants
qui, selon la société, n'étaient pas intéressés.
Et eux-mêmes ne savaient pas qu'ils étaient intéressés.
Et en écrivant et en débattant,
plutôt que de voir les films comme des objets,
ils ont commencé à s'y voir eux-mêmes.
Une de mes tantes est une merveilleuse conteuse.
En quelques instants, elle peut générer des images
d'une course pieds nus sur la montagne de la Table et du jeu des gendarmes et des voleurs.
Il y a peu, elle m'a raconté
qu'en 1948, deux de ses sœurs et mon père
sont allés en bateau en Israël sans mes grands-parents.
Quand les marins se sont mutinés en mer pour exiger des conditions plus humaines,
ce sont ces adolescents qui ont nourri l'équipage.
J'avais plus de 40 ans quand mon père est mort.
Il n'a jamais mentionné ce voyage.
Ma grand-mère maternelle a quitté précipitamment l'Europe
sans son mari, mais avec sa fille de trois ans
et des diamants cousus dans l'ourlet de sa jupe.
Après deux ans dans la clandestinité,
mon grand-père est apparu à Londres.
Il ne s'en est jamais remis.
Et son histoire a été tue pendant qu'il s'intégrait.
Mon histoire a commencé en Angleterre
avec une table rase et le silence de mes parents immigrés.
J'avais "Anne Frank", "La grande évasion",
"Shoah", "Le triomphe de la volonté".
C'est Leni Riefenstahl
dans sa propagande nazie élégante
qui a donné un contexte à ce que ma famille a dû endurer.
Ces films contenaient ce qu'il était trop douloureux de dire tout haut
et ils me sont devenus plus utiles
que les chuchotements des survivants
et le tatouage brièvement entrevu
sur le poignet d'une tante célibataire.
Les puristes peuvent penser que la fiction dilue
la quête d'une compréhension humaine véritable,
que le film est trop rudimentaire
pour raconter une histoire complexe et détaillée
ou que les réalisateurs donne plus d'importance au drame qu'à la vérité.
Mais dans ces bobines résident un but et un sens.
Comme a dit un enfant de 12 ans après avoir vu "Le magicien d'Oz",
"Tout le monde devrait regarder ce film,
parce que sans ça,
on pourrait ne pas se rendre compte que les autres ont aussi un cœur."
Nous estimons la lecture, pourquoi n'estimons-nous pas le cinéma avec la même passion?
Considérez que "Citizen Kane" a autant de valeur que Jane Austen.
Acceptez que "La loi de la rue", comme Tennyson,
offre un paysage émotionnel et une compréhension accrue
qui fonctionnent ensemble.
Chacun d'entre eux est une oeuvre d'art mémorable,
une brique du mur qui nous représente.
Ce n'est pas grave si nous nous souvenons mieux de Tom Hanks
que de l'astronaute Jim Lovell
ou si le visage de Ben Kingsley s'est superposé à celui de Gandhi.
Et bien que fictifs, Eve Harrington, Howard Beale, Mildred Pierce
sont des occasions de découvrir
ce que cela signifie d'être humain
et ils sont aussi utiles pour comprendre notre vie et notre époque
que Shakespeare l'est pour illuminer le monde de l'Angleterre élisabéthain.
Nous pensions que le film,
où se rencontrent dans les histoires
le drame, la musique, la littérature et l'expérience humaine
éveillerait et inspirerait les jeunes qui participaient au FILMCLUB.
Ce que nous ne pouvions pas nous imaginer,
ce sont les améliorations visibles
au point de vue du comportement, de la confiance et de la réussite scolaire.
Des élèves qui traînaient les pieds autrefois se précipitent maintenant à l'école, parlent à leurs enseignants,
se battent, non pas dans la cour d'école,
mais pour choisir le film de la semaine suivant,
des jeunes gens qui ont trouvé le moyen de s'autodéfinir, de l'ambition
et un intérêt pour l'éducation et l'engagement social
dans les histoires dont ils ont été témoins.
Nos membres démentent les descriptions binaires
qu'on utilise si souvent pour décrire nos jeunes.
Ils ne sont ni des sauvages ni des myopes égocentriques.
Comme d'autres jeunes,
ils négocient un monde avec des choix infinis,
mais avec peu de culture expliquant comment trouver des expériences significatives.
Nous étions surpris de l'attitude
de ceux qui se définissent
par la taille de la virgule sur leurs chaussures
alors que l'acquisition était la seule narration que nous leur ayons offert.
Si nous voulons des valeurs différentes,
nous devons raconter une histoire différente,
une histoire qui comprend que le récit individuel
est une composante essentielle de l'identité d'une personne,
qu'un récit collectif
est une composante essentielle d'une identité culturelle,
et que sans cela, il est impossible de s'imaginer
comme membre d'un groupe.
Parce que quand ces personnes rentrent à la maison
après avoir vu "Fenêtre sur cour"
et lèvent les yeux sur l'édifice voisin,
ils ont les outils pour se demander qui, mis à part eux,
est là
et quelle est leur histoire.
Merci
(Applaudissements)